Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is a truth universally acknowledged that two men in possession of a podcast must be in want of a weekly subject. And especially, Dominic, to paraphrase Dickens, when it's the worst of times, it's the worst of times. It's the age of foolishness.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这是一个世人皆知的真理：任何一个拥有播客的男人，必然渴望一个每周主题。特别是，多米尼克，借用狄更斯的话来说，当它是最糟糕的时代，它就是最糟糕的时代。这是愚蠢的时代。
It's the age of foolishness. Only Tom Holland there could possibly believe that he could improve on Charles Dickens. So let's get on with the podcast. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Today we want to talk about historical fiction. And the reason we want to talk about historical fiction is that a few weeks ago Tom and I had a, I think what the critics would call a minor spat, about the merits of the great Patrick O'Brien. And Tom's final comment, if I can just read it out to damn him for all eternity, is everyone tells me they're great, he wrote on Twitter. But honestly, after 30 pages of rope, I had lost the will to live.
这是愚蠢的时代。只有汤姆·霍兰才会觉得他能超越查尔斯·狄更斯。我们还是继续播客吧。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天我们想聊聊历史小说。我们想聊历史小说的原因是，几周前，汤姆和我发生了一场，我想评论界会称之为“小小的争执”，关于伟大的帕特里克·奥布里安的优点。汤姆的最后一条评论——如果我可以把它读出来以让他遗臭万年——是他在推特上写道：“每个人都告诉我它们很棒，但是说实话，看了30页的绳索之后，我已经失去了活下去的意志。”
And this caused well justified uproar. So we decided it needed the full podcast treatment. Emma Darwin said, You too, Tom. Having grown up on C.S. Forrester, I'm sure I'd love Aubrey Maturin as much as so many mainly male friends told me I would, but the gorgeous period detail never adds up to anything,
这引起了完全合乎情理的轩然大波。所以我们决定用一整期播客来深入探讨。艾玛·达尔文说：“你也是，汤姆。从小读着C·S·福里斯特长大，我确信我会像那么多主要由男性组成的朋友告诉我的那样，深深爱上奥布里和马图林，但华丽的时代细节却从未拼凑出什么实质内容，
just sits there. You're quite wrong, Emma, I have to say. No, very, very wise. Emma, you are right. Well, Chris Kendall said said this is like giving up on Proust after three pages because it's just about cake um Chris Kendall is obviously a very fine judge um anyway Tom Patrick O'Brien you're not a fan it's too much rope for you you're gonna give it another go I don't think so there's so much I want to read and they just kind of the
只是死气沉沉地呆在那里。”艾玛，你大错特错了，我必须这么说。不，非常非常明智。艾玛，你是对的。好吧，克里斯·肯达尔说，这就像读了三页普鲁斯特就放弃一样，因为里面全都是关于蛋糕的事。嗯，克里斯·肯达尔显然是个非常有品位的裁判。嗯，不管怎样，汤姆，帕特里克·奥布里安，你不是他的粉丝，对他来说绳索太多了，你还要再试一次吗？我不这么认为。有那么多我想读的东西，而一想到
thought of plowing the way through all that stuff about yardarms and foxholes and weevils and stuff. I'm just, I'm simply not interested. And I wasn't ever particularly interested in Hornblower either. I think novels about the admirals and midshipmen and things in Nelson's, I'm just not interested. I'd much rather read, you know, the actual campaigns of Nelson. All right right fair enough well let's get into historical fiction so do you read historical fiction for pleasure that's obviously the first question are you a historical fiction buff well like most men i basically stopped
要啃完所有关于横桁、散兵坑和象鼻虫之类的内容，我就……我 simplesmente（葡萄牙语，意为：我简直）不感兴趣。而且我过去对霍恩布洛尔也不是特别感兴趣。我认为关于纳尔逊时期的海军上将、见习海军军官等的小说，我就是不感兴趣。我宁愿去读，你知道的，纳尔逊的实际战役。好吧，好吧，很有道理。那我们切入历史小说吧。所以，你为了消磨时间而读历史小说吗？这显然是第一个问题，你是个历史小说迷吗？嗯，像大多数男人一样，我基本上在40岁时就停止
reading fiction when i was 40 oh for goodness sake so i i used to read a lot i mean i read historical fiction obsessively when I was a child. I'm sure lots of people who become interested in history, it's a kind of gateway drug to it. Yeah. I've read a lot of historical fiction over the course of my life. But yeah, basically, I mean, about for about 10 years, I haven't really read it. But I'm aware that that's because I actually I've become more and more interested in reading history and less and less interested in reading fiction. And that's weird. That corresponds to the fact we used the fact, I began my writing career as a novelist. And all the novels were set in historical periods. And I just began to realise that the
阅读小说了。哦，看在上帝的份上。所以，我以前读得很多——我是说，我小时候痴迷地读历史小说。我确信很多对历史产生兴趣的人，它就像通往历史的某种“入门毒品”。是的。在我的一生中，我读过很多历史小说。但是，是的，基本上，大约有10年时间，我真的没有读过它。但我意识到，那是因为实际上我对阅读历史越来越感兴趣，而对阅读小说越来越不感兴趣。这很奇怪。这与以下事实相吻合：我们曾利用这一事实，即我以小说家身份开始我的写作生涯。而所有的设定都发生在历史时期。我只是开始意识到，
history was just much more interesting than the bits that I was making up. So that's why, essentially, why I changed course. You're selling the listener short a little here. You weren't just a novelist. You're a novelist of historically themed vampire fiction. I was. Yes, I was. Yes, I was. Let's get into the nitty gritty. Yeah, I was very interested in people's attitudes to the supernatural, for instance. And I enjoyed writing, said, in historical periods because it was a way of accessing that.
历史比我凭空捏造的部分要有趣得多。所以，这基本上就是我改变方向的原因。你在这里有点贬低听众了。你不仅仅是个小说家。你是一位以历史为主题的吸血鬼小说家。我是。是的，我是。是的，我是。让我们切入正题。是的，我对人们对超自然的态度非常感兴趣，例如。我喜欢以历史时期为背景进行写作，因为这是接触这种态度的一种方式。
And for me, actually, one of the things that i find fascinating about the past is is all the kind of weird stuff that people believed in the past and i'm sure that in 200 years time people will look back at art you know 2021 again wow they believe that i mean actually we were talking about that last week on conspiracy theories people say they believe q anon blimey yeah so in a way i think i think fact is more interesting than fiction is basically what i've come to believe. But it's interesting what you say about it being a gateway drug, because I was thinking about this today, sort of looking forward to the podcast,
对我来说，实际上，让我对过去着迷的一点是，人们在过去相信的所有那些奇怪的事情。而且我确信，在200年后，人们会回看艺术，你知道的，2021年，然后说：“哇，他们竟然相信那个？”事实上，我们上周在讨论阴谋论时就谈到过这个，人们说他们相信匿名者Q，天哪，是的。所以从某种程度上说，我认为事实比小说更有趣，这基本上是我开始相信的观点。但你提到它是一种“入门毒品”，这很有趣，因为我今天在想这个，有点像在期待这期播客，
about when I first, the first history books I read, like most people listening to this, were the Lady Bird history books. And they were sort of packaged and presented in exactly the same way as the Lady Bird books about myths and legends. Or for me, the Lady Bird books that I love are Robin Hood and King Arthur and then I went from them to Kings and Queens of England, Nelson, Elizabeth I and all these other stories without really seeing a sort of disjuncture. It seems like part of the same thing and obviously kids history books are often written if they're any good they're written in a sort of slightly
关于我第一次，我读的第一批历史图书，就像听这期节目的大多数人一样，是“瓢虫”历史图书（Ladybird books）。它们被包装和呈现的方式，与“瓢虫”关于神话和传说的图书完全一样。或者对我来说，我喜欢的“瓢虫”图书是《罗宾汉》和《亚瑟王》，然后我从这些过渡到《英格兰的国王与女王》、《纳尔逊》、《伊丽莎白一世》以及所有这些其他故事，而没有真正看到某种断层。这似乎是同一事物的一部分，显然儿童历史图书通常都是这样写的，如果它们还不错的话，它们会以一种略微
fictionalised style, aren't they? I mean, how many people come to Roman Britain through Rosemary Sutcliffe, The Eagle of the Ninth, or, you know, come to any of the great stories of history through fiction rather than from fact? You know, for me, I mean, for me, what got me particularly interested in the Romans was Asterix, which I suppose, in a way kinds of novels i mean born destiny um yeah and then you're right that rosemary suck cliff who do people still read her i mean for the benefit of yeah they do they're still my son reads them i mean they have they the folio society that's amazing yeah we're a very normal family. Full of 1950s historical fiction. I don't know. I mean, I thought all her books were wonderful.
小说化的风格来写，不是吗？我是说，有多少人通过罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫的《第九军团之鹰》走近罗马不列颠，或者，你知道的，通过小说而不是事实走入历史的伟大故事中？你知道，对我来说，让我对罗马人特别感兴趣的是《高卢英雄历险记》，我想在某种程度上，这也是某种小说，嗯，然后你是对的，罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫，现在还有人读她吗？我是说，为了……是的，他们读，它们仍然……我儿子在读。我是说，它们有……弗里奥学会版，太棒了。我们是一个非常正常的家庭。
There was a fantastic one about the Roman invasion in AD 43 that I think was all about a war dog. So it was a kind of Jack London, only Celtic. And then, of course, The Eagle of the Ninth is the absolute classic. And that clearly does have an enduring influence. There was a whole rash of films that came out a couple of years ago about people going north of Hadrian's Wall, looking for kind of lost eagles and things like that. So that clearly does have an enduring influence.
充满了20世纪50年代的历史小说。我不知道。我是说，我觉得她所有的书都很棒。有一本关于公元43年罗马入侵的精彩小说，我想那全部是关于一只战犬的。所以它有点像杰克·伦敦的作品，只不过是凯尔特风格的。然后，当然，《第九军团之鹰》是绝对的经典。那显然具有持久的影响力。几年前涌现出一大批电影，都是关于人们去哈德良长城以北，寻找某种迷失的鹰标之类的事情。所以这显然具有持久的影响力。
And the other one you talked about, King Arthur, is The Sword at Sunset. That's for adults, though, isn't it? That's brilliant. Yeah, but that is a fabulous novel about a kind of historical Arthur who in the fifth century after the Romans have left. And there's a kind of climactic scene after they've won the Battle of Baden against the invading Saxons.
你谈到的另一本书，关于亚瑟王的，是《日落时的剑》。那是写给成人的，对吧？那太棒了。是的，但那是一部极好的小说，讲的是罗马人离开后，公元五世纪的一种历史上的亚瑟王。并且在他们击败入侵的萨克森人的巴顿山战役之后，有一个高潮迭起的场景。
And Arthur says that they are still upholding the values of Rome and they dream that the emperor in distant Constantinople will know it. And in a sense, it's Rosemary Sutcliffe in all those novels is casting Rome as the kind of embodiment of civilisation. And therefore, in those novels, you have a clear sense that Rome is good and that barbarism is bad. Yeah, that's that's a that's a kind of polarity that I think children particularly respond to. But of course, part of the fascination of history is that you start to realise that those slightly stark polarities aren't actually true. Yes, true. Yeah, but that's but i think that's part of i mean that's part of
亚瑟说他们仍在维护罗马的价值观，他们梦想着遥远君士坦丁堡的皇帝会知道这一点。从某种意义上说，罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫在所有这些小说中，都把罗马塑造成了文明的某种化身。因此，在那些小说中，你有这样一种清晰的感觉：罗马是好的，野蛮是坏的。是的，那是一种……那是一种孩子们特别有共鸣的两极分化。但当然，历史的迷人之处的一部分在于，你开始意识到那些略显冷酷的两极分化实际上并非事实。是的，确实。是的，但那是……但我认为那是……的一部分，我是说那是……的一部分。
children's history whether it's fact or fiction right that you're setting up these myths that you later debunk i mean actually talking of that and in sort of stories that you debunk i used to read i mean tons of kind of g.a henty style imperial did you yeah i mean this was a cartoon and all that precisely yeah this will astonish people and all that precisely yeah this will astonish people who are used to my incredibly incredibly left-wing views on um british imperialism but all that stuff those sort of rousing stories they do more i think to get people interested in history than any number of i mean let's be honest they do more than any number of academic history books don't they?
儿童历史，无论是事实还是虚构，对吧？你正在建立这些你后来会揭穿的神话。事实上，说到这个，在那些你所揭穿的故事中，我过去常常读——我是说，成吨的那种G·A·亨蒂风格的帝国主义……你读过吗？是的，这是一个卡通片之类的一切，完全如此。是的，这会震惊到那些习惯了我对英国帝国主义持有的……极其极其左翼观点的人，所有这些东西，那些振奋人心的故事，它们对让人们产生历史兴趣的作用，比任何数量的……我是说，老实说，它们比任何数量的学术历史书的作用都要大，不是吗？
But again, you've got the same thing because in those books, the guiding assumption is that the British Empire is positive, that it ventures into darkest Africa or whatever. I mean, it's kind of still there in Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom. Yeah, absolutely. That gives you a kind of, again,
但同样，你有同样的东西，因为在那些书中，核心的假设是英国殖民帝国是积极的，它冒险进入黑暗的非洲或任何地方。我是说，它在《印第安纳·琼斯与魔宫传奇》中仍然存在。是的，绝对的。这给了你一种，再次，
a kind of clear sense of goodies and baddies that obviously now would not be acceptable. You wouldn't get novels written like that. And I guess that what's interesting about that is that it suggests that historical novels themselves become historical artefacts, that they become actually very, very rapidly. Yeah, of course they do. I mean, you look at, but actually the goodies and baddies thing
一种对好人和坏人的清晰感觉，这在现在显然是不可接受的。你不会看到写成这样的小说。我想，有趣的是，这表明历史小说本身变成了历史人工制品，它们非常非常迅速地变成了历史。是的，它们当然会。我是说，你看看……但实际上，好人和坏人的事情
is an interesting thing, isn't it? Because you think about the most successful, or the most sort of prestigious historical novels of the last 10 years, Hilary Mantel's books. They have goodies and baddies in. Thomas Cromwell is the goody, Thomas More is the baddy. And that is a complete reversal of the Robert Bolt,
是一件很有趣的事情，不是吗？因为你想想过去10年中最成功、或最负盛名的历史小说——希拉里·曼特尔的书。里面有好人和坏人。托马斯·克伦威尔是好人，托马斯·莫尔是坏人。这完全颠覆了罗伯特·博尔特的
A Man for All Seasons, where it was the other way around. And I think what's interesting about Wolf Hall and that trilogy is is hillary mantel's attempt to overcome what is perhaps another issue with historical fiction which is that you know what's going to happen whereas you have to the not the skill of the novelist is to persuade you that that the characters within that historical sweep do not know what's going to happen and so hillary mantel does it very cleverly by putting it all in the present tense so you have a sense of events happening um as she she writes
《四季人》，那部作品里正好相反。我认为《狼厅》和那部三部曲有趣的地方在于，希拉里·曼特尔试图克服历史小说的另一个潜在问题，那就是你知道将会发生什么，而小说家的技巧在于说服你，身处历史洪流中的角色并不知道将要发生什么，所以希拉里·曼特尔非常聪明地通过全部使用现在时态来做到这一点，这样当你阅读它时，
about it and i guess the converse of that the the other attempt and it wouldn't traditionally be thought of as a historical novel or a series of historical novels would be the game of thrones novels which are objectively completely fantasy but obviously take elements of um recognizable history so the core of it is the wars of the roses and if you read a series of novels set in the wars of the roses you know exactly what's going to happen i mean you just have to look at a kind of a history book to know you know who's going to die who's going to win the battles and so on part of the the thrill of game of the thrones is that you you know you get the same archetypes you get the same patterns but you don't know who's going to die.
你会有事件正在发生的感觉。我想，与之相反的尝试——传统上不会被认为是一部历史小说或一系列历史小说——将是《权力的游戏》小说，它们客观上完全是奇幻小说，但显然汲取了可识别的历史元素，所以它的核心是玫瑰战争。如果你阅读一套以玫瑰战争为背景的小说，你确切地知道将要发生什么。我是说，你只需看一本历史书就知道谁会死、谁会赢得战役等等。《权力的游戏》惊悚之处的一部分在于，你得到了相同的原型，你得到了相同的模式，但你不知道谁会死。
And I think that that's a kind of interesting way of spicing it up. That's interesting because the Game of Thrones novels are partly inspired by a French series. Have you ever read these books by Maurice Drouin, Accursed Kings? Set in the Hundred Years' War, aren't they? Yeah, set in the Hundred Years' War. And they're a strange thing to read because as an English reader, you don't really know what's going to happen. You don't know all the characters
我认为这是给它增添趣味的一种有趣方式。这很有趣，因为《权力的游戏》小说部分灵感来自法国的一个系列。你读过莫里斯·德鲁恩的《被诅咒的国王》这些书吗？以百年战争为背景，对吧？是的，以百年战争为背景。读起来感觉很奇怪，因为作为一个英国读者，你真的不知道会发生什么。你不认识所有的角色，
because they're all these sort of French noblemen, the sort of Warwick the Kingmakers and Simon de Montforts of French medieval history who are presumably well-known or were well-known to sort of 1950s French readers, but are basically completely unknown to any but specialist English readers. So there you're reading historical fiction that's quite fun.
因为他们都是法国贵族，法国中世纪历史上的那些“造王者华威”和“西蒙·德·孟福尔”，他们对20世纪50年代的法国读者来说可能是众所周知的，或者曾经是众所周知的，但除了英国的专业读者之外，对其他人来说基本上完全是未知的。所以你在那里阅读的历史小说相当有趣。
I mean, they're not great works of literature, but they're quite engaging. But you have this strange experience as a reader that you don't know what everybody else knows who's reading it. Well, I remember from the English point of view, Arthur Conan Doyle's The White Company and Sir Nigel, which is set in the Hundred Years' War, but from the English side. Sir Nigel, that's not a name you choose now, is it?
我是说，它们不是伟大的文学作品，但相当引人入胜。但作为一个读者，你会有这样一种奇怪的体验：你不知道其他所有人——那些正在阅读它的人——所知道的事情。好吧，我从英国的角度记得，阿瑟·柯南·道尔的《白衣军团》和《奈杰尔爵士》，背景也是百年战争，但却是从英国的角度。奈杰尔爵士，现在你不会选这个名字，对吧？
And when I read it, it features Sir John Shandos, who's a real central figure in the Hundred Years' War, and is cast as the absolute model of chivalry. And it features the Black Prince and the Battle of Poitiers and all kinds of kind of truthful elements. But it's very much, I suppose, an Edwardian take on it. And chivalry is something true and authentic and you don't really get the peasant's perspective. But actually what I found the most brilliant section of the Game of Thrones novels was the sequence in, I think it's the second and third
当我读到它时，里面有约翰·尚多斯爵士，他是百年战争中真正的核心人物，被塑造成了骑士精神的绝对模范。它还以黑太子和普瓦捷战役以及各种真实元素为特色。但我猜这非常具有爱德华时代对它的看法。骑士精神是真实而正宗的东西，你并没有真正看到农民的角度。但实际上，我发现《权力的游戏》小说中最精彩的部分是，我认为是在第二本和第三本中，
ones, where basically you have the Hundred Years' War going on. And this tends not to be featured in the TV series, but in the novels, you get a brilliant sense of what it must have been like to be a peasant, basically, in the Hundred Years' War. It's kind of, you know, companies of gangs of armed thugs roaming around, that the lords in their castles are essentially predators. I mean, it's absolutely terrifying vision. And I think vastly truer to The Hundred Years' War, even though it's set in Westeros, than anything, any kind of historical version of The Hundred Years' War that I've read. And I think that that's a kind of really interesting slant on what can be done with historical fiction that actually doesn't have to be entirely accurate.
基本上有百年战争正在进行。这在电视剧中往往没有得到体现，但在小说中，你对身处百年战争中的农民到底是什么感觉有了极好的体会。这有点像，你知道的，成群结队的武装暴徒四处游荡，城堡里的领主本质上就是掠夺者。我是说，这是一种绝对恐怖的愿景。而且我认为，尽管它以维斯特洛为背景，但它比我读过的任何百年战争的历史版本都要真实得多。我认为这是对历史小说可以做的事情的一种非常有趣的扭曲，它实际上不必完全准确。
And in many ways, if it's not accurate, perhaps you get a better sense of what the reality was like. Yeah, I completely agree with you about that. It's the second book of Game of Thrones. So the war's just started and they're sort of going around raping and pillaging. So this is the stuff that you don't expect in a sort of historical fantasy novel. It's the sort of Second World War style gritty realism um we'll get onto that question of accuracy in a second but before we do that um tell me do you are there some historical books that sort of historical novels that really stand out to you as having meant more than others or having caught a period better than others well there's one we mentioned already, which is Ian Peer's instance
而且在许多情况下，如果不准确，也许你能更好地体会到现实是什么样的。是的，我完全同意你的看法。那是《权力的游戏》第二本。所以战争刚刚开始，他们到处强奸和掠夺。所以这些是你不会在一类历史奇幻小说中期望看到的东西。这是一种第二次世界大战风格的残酷现实主义。我们一会儿再讨论准确性这个问题，但在那之前，告诉我，有没有一些历史书籍——某种历史小说——作为比其他书意义更重大或更好地捕捉了一个时代而真正脱颖而出？嗯，有一本是我们已经提到的，
of the finger post, which if I had to nominate the single best historical novel I've read, that would get my vote. And the reason for that is that it offers multiple perspectives. So it's four different perspectives on, I think it's set at the end of the protectorate, the beginnings of the restoration. And it's a kind of a mystery. And you get the perspective of, you know, a scholar at Oxford and a cavalier and so on. And I think that the idea that there isn't an objective kind of sense of what historical fact is, is brilliantly evoked through that. But also it's brilliant because without giving anything away, there's a twist that is true to how people in the 17th century would have understood the world, but isn't necessarily true to how we would see it. And I think that historical fiction that I tend not to like is condescending,
那就是伊恩·皮尔斯的《指尖巨匠》（An Instance of the Fingerpost），如果我必须提名我读过的单一最佳历史小说，那将获得我的投票。原因在于它提供了多个视角。所以它是关于——我想它以护国公时期结束、王政复辟开始为背景——四个不同的视角。它是一种神秘事件。你得到了诸如牛津学者的视角、保王党人的视角等等。我认为“不存在对历史事实的客观理解”这种观点，通过那本书得到了精彩的唤起。而且它也很棒，因为在不剧透的情况下，有一个转折，它符合17世纪的人理解世界的方式，但未必符合我们看待它的方式。我认为我往往不喜欢的那种居高临下的历史小说，
is historical fiction that is condescending towards the culture of the age. So although I like C.J. Sansom, for instance, very much, I find that as novels, very gripping, as he'd done, it's very, very gripping. Or indeed, Bernard Cornwall's Lost Kingdom set in the Anglo-Saxon period. Again, they're kind of very thrilling and exciting what I dislike about them
是对那个时代的文化采取居高临下的态度的历史小说。因此，尽管我非常喜欢C·J·桑森，比如，我发现作为小说，非常引人入胜，正如他所做的那样，非常非常引人入胜。或者确实，伯纳德·康威尔以盎格鲁-撒克逊时期为背景的《失落的王国》。同样，它们非常惊险刺激，而我不喜欢它们的地方在于，
is that both lead characters are kind of cast as liberal humanist sceptics who yeah
两个主角都被塑造成了自由主义人文主义怀疑论者，是的，
they're Philip Pullman and Richard Dawkins aren't they yes basically and so you have this guy who's been
他们是菲利普·普尔曼和理查德·道金斯，对吧？是的，基本上是这样。所以你会遇到这样一个家伙，他曾经
in a monastery and is now kind of saying I don't hold with Catholicism or Protestantism. It's all nonsense. Let people believe what they think. But I'm just going to carry on reading the God delusion. Essentially, it's the perspective of a 21st century liberal skeptic.
在修道院里，现在有点在说：“我不同意天主教或新教。这全是无稽之谈。让人们相信他们自己的想法吧。但我还是要继续阅读《上帝错觉》。”本质上，这是21世纪自由怀疑论者的视角。
And maybe you need, I mean, maybe people need that, a kind of sense of continuity. But I don't think so I think it's kind of more interesting to um to try and get people to to see the world in so far as possible through eyes that are not those of the well that's the point of fiction right I mean yeah exactly but that's true of the Bernard Cornwell right I like the Bernard Cornwell books as sort of holiday reads or whatever but it does always amuse me that utrid the lead character is this 21st century guy trapped in a half saxon i mean he kills people and he's got very good with an axe but but he often says like i don't like christianity you know i i they're very they're all hypocrites all this kind of stuff which is completely implausible yes yes uh uh do you have a favorite um well we mentioned before the leopard um by giuseppe
也许你需要——我是说，也许人们需要那种东西，一种连续性感。但我不这么认为。我认为更有趣的是，尽可能地让人们通过并非……的眼睛去观察世界。好吧，这就是小说的意义，对吧？我是说，是的， exatamente（葡萄牙语，意为：完全正确），但伯纳德·康威尔的作品也是如此。我喜欢伯纳德·康威尔的书作为某种假日读物或别的什么，但它总是让我觉得好笑的是，主角乌特雷德是一个被困在半撒克逊人身体里的21世纪家伙——我是说，他杀人，他很擅长用斧头——但他经常说诸如“我不喜欢基督教，你知道的，他们都是伪君子”之类的话，诸如此类完全不可信的话。是的，是的。呃，你有一个最喜欢的……
tamasi de lampedusa and i think that is a brilliant book it's a one-off so it was published in the mid-20th century it's looking back at the period of italian unification it's a very conservative book it's a book about the sort of anxiety of change so it's this guy who the the prince who is sort of besieged by the rise of the italian middle classes and by the sort of um the new values of nationalism and what he sees as vulgarity and and all this kind of thing but it's beautifully written it's a sort of one great one-off um it has this famous stuff about for everything to stay the same everything has to change which has become a sort of um become one of the great sort of mottos of intellectual conservatism liberal conservatism i guess the other book that i'm i don't think anybody mentioned on twitter that surprises me um it's probably the most famous historical novel is war and peace
嗯，我们之前提到了《豹》，作者朱塞佩·托马西·迪·兰佩杜萨，我认为那是一本杰作。这是一本独一无二的书——它出版于20世纪中叶，回溯了意大利统一时期。这是一本非常保守的书，一本关于变革焦虑的书——所以它是这个家伙，王子，被意大利中产阶级的崛起以及民族主义的新价值观和他所认为的粗俗以及所有这类事情所包围，但它写得非常优美，这是一本伟大的独一无二的作品。它有关于“为了让一切保持原样，一切都必须改变”的名言，这已经成为一种……成为知识保守主义、自由保守主义的伟大座右铭之一，我想。另一本我在推特上没看到任何人提到、这让我感到惊讶的书，可能也是最著名的历史小说，那就是《战争与和平》。
yeah um so there you've got a book that's not just a historical novel but it's also about history history and how history works and i i'm very sympathetic to tolstoy's non-great man um school of history the history is sort of made by the masses who don't really know what they're doing and that great men are sort of then imposed on history almost and become nearly the vehicles for for great forces have you are you a war and peace man yes i i well i'm more a dostoevsky man to be honest oh no i can't deal with that the troubled relationship with god and suffering is much more you're just so dark tom you're so deep well this time last year i was actually in saint petersburg
是的，所以在那本书里，你拥有一本不仅是历史小说、而且也是关于历史本身以及历史如何运作的书。我非常赞同托尔斯泰的“非伟人”历史学派，即历史是由并不真正知道自己在做什么的大众所创造的，而伟人随后几乎是被强加给历史，并几乎成为伟大力量的载体。你是《战争与和平》的拥趸吗？是的，我……好吧，说实话，我更倾向于陀思妥耶夫斯基。哦，不，我受不了那个。那种与上帝和苦难的纠结关系要多得多……汤姆，你太黑暗了，你太深沉了。好吧，去年这个时候我实际上在圣彼得堡，
i've been commissioned by the economist to write an article about crime and punishment. So I was going around St. Petersburg in the footsteps of the murderous Raskolnikov. But yeah, of course, I mean, Tolstoy's great. But what I, my chief memory of reading War and Peace is that, you know, it's brilliant. You get through, you've got the bottle of Baradino and all that kind of stuff. And then right at the end, you've got this 50 page essay on why napoleon isn't very important that's right yeah it's very strange that is a bit like kind of climbing a mountain and you see what you think's the peak and you get there and then there's another bloody great peak waiting for you to crawl up
我受《经济学人》委托写一篇关于《罪与罚》的文章。所以我沿着杀人犯拉斯柯尔尼科夫的足迹走访圣彼得堡。但是，是的，当然，托尔斯泰很伟大。不过我读《战争与和平》的主要记忆是，你知道的，它很精彩。你读完了——你读了关于博罗金诺战役及所有这类内容。然后就在最后，你有这篇长达50页的论文，论述为什么拿破仑其实不是很重要。没错，是的，这很奇怪。这有点像爬山，你看到了你以为是顶峰的东西，当你到达那里时，却发现还有另一个该死的大山峰等着你去攀爬。
and that i do remember being being quite a slog um one one one other thing i think quite strongly about historical fiction is that it's very much easier to write it um if it's set in a period in which novels actually exist so yeah so if you so basically if you let's say that the fiction begins well i suppose it begins with with don quixote and cervantes but let's say in the 18th century because that's when you start to get mass novels yeah so if you want to set a novel in the 18th century you can read richardson or or um smollett or whatever yeah if you want to write something set in the in the in the regency you can read jane austen if you want to write something set in the in the in the regency you can read jane austen if you want to write something victorian period you can read zola or dickens or whatever and so on
我确实记得那是一段相当艰难的旅程。关于历史小说，我还有一个非常坚定的看法，那就是如果你把背景设定在小说实际存在的时期，写起来会容易得多。所以，基本上，如果你让……假设小说开始于……我想它始于塞万提斯的《堂吉诃德》，但假设在18世纪，因为那时你开始拥有大众小说。所以如果你想以18世纪为背景写一部小说，你可以读理查森或斯莫利特之类的小说。如果你想写以摄政时期为背景的作品，你可以读简·奥斯汀。如果你想写以摄政时期为背景的作品，你可以读简·奥斯汀。如果你想写维多利亚时代，你可以读左拉或狄更斯之类的小说，诸如此类。
but it becomes much much harder if you go beyond that period so into the middle ages or classical period or um ancient egypt it just in ancient egypt it's just really difficult you know for a man to get out of bed and walk through a door because we can't we don't know how an egyptian would describe that yeah so agatha christie has an ancient egyptian have you ever read agatha christie's ancient egyptian murder mystery to me at least i think it's called is it appointment with death i can't remember the title and anyway it's not very good because she's so clearly out of her comfort zone and you just don't believe any of these people exist. It's completely mad.
但如果你超越了那个时期，进入中世纪、古典时期或古埃及，那就变得难得多。在古埃及，要让一个男人起床并走过一门槛，真的非常困难，因为我们不知道一个埃及人会如何描述这一点。所以阿加莎·克里斯蒂写过一部古埃及题材的小说。你读过阿加莎·克里斯蒂的古埃及谋杀悬疑小说吗？对我来说，至少，我想它叫《尼罗河上的惨案》？我不记得书名了。无论如何，它写得不是很好，因为她显然超出了她的舒适区，你根本不相信这些人的存在。这完全是疯了。
Ah, the little grey cells that said... No, as you say, I mean, because you sort of think this... I even think this with... I mean, I don't think this all the time, but I even think this with, say, Bernard Cornwell's books, which are narrated by Uhtred. He's telling you the story. But you do sort of think to yourself,
啊，那些小小的灰色细胞……不，正如你所说，因为你会这样想……我甚至对……我的意思是，我并不总是这样想，但我甚至对伯纳德·康威尔的书也有这种想法，这些书是由乌特雷德叙述的。他在给你讲故事。但你确实会对自己说，
not only why is he thinking like a 21st century kind of liberal, but also, why is he using this essentially 18th, 19th century literary form to order his thoughts? And the way he... Well, well, and I think the answer for that is that the historical novel is basically invented by Walter Scott. That's true. yeah. You know, in the early 19th century. And so, in a sense, the default mode for historical novel is kind of early 19th century. And even though people don't read Scott anymore, the kind of the influence of it lingers on whenever people kind of write. I mean, it's a kind of constant temptation and and so you mentioned agatha
不仅为什么他的想法像一个21世纪的自由主义者，而且为什么他要使用这种基本上是18、19世纪的文学形式来整理他的思绪？他那……好吧，我认为答案是历史小说基本上是由沃尔特·司各特发明的。那是真的。是的。你知道，在19世纪初。所以，从某种意义上说，历史小说的默认模式有点像19世纪初。尽管人们不再读司各特了，但它的影响每当人们写作时依然挥之不去。我的意思是，这是一种持续的诱惑。所以你提到了阿加莎·克里斯蒂写古埃及，我认为人们绕过这个问题的途径之一，比如说，“你如何写一部以古罗马为背景的小说？”或者其他什么，正是专注于时代错误。想想林西·戴维斯，她写了一系列法尔科小说，一个关于古罗马侦探的系列。时代错误本身就是重点。我的意思是，有各种各样的巨大细节。一切都非常准确，有许多角色。你知道，罗马被精彩地唤起，
christie writing about ancient egypt i think one way for for people to get around the problem of say you know how do you how do you write a novel set in ancient rome or whatever is is precisely to focus in on anachronism so thinking of lindsey davis who's written a series of falco novels a series of who's a detective in ancient Rome. The anachronism kind of is the point. I mean, there's all kinds of tremendous detail. It's all very accurate, lots of characters. You know, Rome is brilliantly evoked,
所有这类事情。但你不会遇到试图寻找一种适合罗马时期的风格的问题，因为你可以，你知道的，尽情享受时代错误。然而像玛格丽特·尤瑟纳尔的《哈德良回忆录》或非常无聊的《我，克劳狄斯》……好吧，它是——我同意它是无聊的，因为它是试图模仿哈德良的声音，但它太准确了，以现代小说的标准来看，它相当沉闷。是的，我数
all that kind of thing. But you don't have the issue of trying to find a kind of style that is appropriate to the Roman period because you can, you know, you revel in the anachronism. Whereas something like um margaret usenor's uh memoirs of hadrian or indeed very boring um i claudius yeah well it is it it is i agree it is boring because it's it's an attempt to to mimic hadrian's voice but it's so accurate that by the standards of a modern novel you know it it's quite dull yes i count
贝利撒留，罗伯特·格雷夫斯的《伯爵贝利撒留》，我发现它极其无聊，因为它读起来就像是一场战役的拜占庭式叙述，而《我，克劳狄斯》之所以行之有效，是因为它的原始素材太棒了。我是说，他基本上是在改编苏埃托尼乌斯和塔西佗，那是如此有趣，有如此大的空间来进行谋杀和堕落，以至于他——克劳狄斯可以像克劳狄斯那样写作。显然，你知道的，这在很大程度上也是格雷夫斯的风格。但我认为《我，克劳狄斯》是我所能想到的、为生活在小说发明之前那个时期的某个人进行内心独白的最成功的尝试，也是最持久的一次尝试。在我们进入休息时间之前——你可能应该这样做——
belisarius robert graze is count palisarius which i find incredibly boring because it just reads like a sort of byzantine account of a campaign whereas um i claudius works because the source material is so brilliant i mean he's basically adapting satonius and tacitus and that is such fun there's such scope for kind of murder and depravity that, you know, he can, Claudius can kind of write as Claudius might have done. I mean, obviously, you know, he's very much Graves as well. But I think I, Claudius is the most successful attempt to ventriloquise somebody from a period before the invention of the novel that I can think of, the most kind of enduring one. Before we go to the break, which you probably should,
我想顺便提一下其中一条推特，因为谈到为某个时期进行内心独白，我认为这最好的例子——我们收到了一个叫波奇科特（Potchcott）的人发来的消息，他说：“你们有时间读乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽的‘闪曼’（Flashman）系列小说吗？”现在，我认为《闪曼》中的叙事声音与任何历史小说中的叙事声音一样出色。它完美地捕捉了对我而言一个维多利亚时代的恶棍会如何讲述所有这些战役故事的方式。而且我认为《闪曼》系列实际上是最聪明的，
I want to just bring up one of the tweets, because talking about ventriloquising a period, I think the best example of this, we had a message from somebody called Potchcott, and he says, do you have any time for George Macdonald Fraser's Flashman books? Now, I think the narrative voice in Flashman is as good as any narrative voice in any historical novel. It absolutely captures for me how a Victorian cad would tell the story of all these campaigns. And I think the Flashman books are the cleverest, actually. I mean, maybe Tolstoy or whatever apart,
除了托尔斯泰之类的人不谈，因为它们极大地戏谑了你对维多利亚时代帝国主义小说的期待，而且它处理大英帝国故事的方式的那种模糊性做得如此巧妙，因为我认为你可以从那个故事中随心所欲地获取任何你喜欢的东西。但我认为这些小说也很大程度上是一个时代的产物，当时对帝国的态度远没有现在这么复杂。我是说，这让我怀疑它是否会……是的，我愿意。里面的语言不是那种我认为……
because they're playing so much with your expectations of victorian imperial fiction and there's the the ambiguity of the way it treats the the story of britain's empire is so cleverly done because you can take of that story whatever you like i think but it is also i think the novels are very much products of a time where the attitude to the empire is less complicated than it is now. I mean, it kind of, I wonder if it would. Yes, I do. The language in it is not the kind of language I think that
即使有人试图为维多利亚时代的人做内心独白也未必会使用的语言。你看，在这里，汤姆，我不同意你的看法。我会说《闪曼》系列实际上反映了一个对帝国的态度比现在更复杂的时代，因为……是的，好吧，那是有可能的，是的。弗雷泽……
even if one was trying to ventriloquise a Victorian would necessarily be used now. You see, here, Tom, I would disagree with you. I would say the flashman books are actually reflective of a time where attitudes to empire are more complicated than they are now because... Yes, OK, that's possible, yeah. Fraser...
闪曼描述了所有这些英国的胜利以及其他一切。毫无疑问他是爱国主义的，闪曼和他的作者都是爱国主义的，其他一切也是如此，毫无疑问他是爱国主义的，并且闪曼和他的作者都是爱国主义的，其他一切也是如此，但与此同时，这些故事总是展现出剥削、贪婪——闪曼本人是个彻头彻尾的懦夫，他是个强奸犯，他剥削人们，诸如此类。帝国的虚伪在被赞美的同时也被赤裸裸地揭露了。所以它鱼与熊掌兼得。
Flashman describes all these sort of British victories and all the rest of it. And there's no doubt that he is patriotic and that both Flashman and his author are patriotic and all the rest of it and and there's no doubt that he is patriotic and that and that that both flashman and his author are patriotic and and and all the rest of it but at the same time the stories always show the exploitation the greed uh flashman himself is a terrible coward and he's a rapist and he sort of exploits people and all the rest of it. And the hypocrisy of Empire is laid bare at the same time that it's celebrated. So it has its cake and eats it.
我同意，我同意。但确实，他确实鱼与熊掌兼得。所以他是个强奸犯和种族主义者。但是一个强奸犯和种族主义者在现在还会像在70年代或任何时候那样被阅读大众所接受吗？不，因为我们更害怕模糊性，我想，因为我们要么想要故事是黑白的，对吧？
I agree, I agree. But yes, he does have his cake and eat it. So he's a rapist and a racist. But would a rapist and a racist now be as acceptable to the reading public as it was in the 70s or whenever it was? No, because we're more frightened of the ambiguity, I think, because we want the story to be black or white, don't we?
我们希望它是善或恶的。我们不喜欢……现在的读者可能会发现使用当前的词汇更加令人不安。但我认为人们对什么是可以接受的模糊性的感觉已经改变和演变了。所以，再次，从这个意义上说，我认为《闪曼》正在变成一种历史人工制品。我是说，我认为对于想要研究过去50年来对帝国的态度不断变化的的历史学家来说，这将是非常非常有趣的。我认为这是一份关键的证据。而且，汤姆，你知道吗？
We want it to be good or evil. We don't like... Readers now would perhaps find it more troubling to use the current words. But I think that people's sense of what is acceptable with ambiguities has changed and evolved. And so, again, in that sense, I think Flashman is becoming a kind of historical artefact. I mean, I think it'd be very, very interesting for historians who want to study changing attitudes to empire over the past 50 years. I think it's a key piece of evidence. And also, Tom, you know what?
你现在不能在大学里教《闪曼》系列小说，因为里面的语言。所以如果你想在课程中使用它们，我的意思是，它们必须带有关于所有材料以及闪曼和叙事者描述它们的各种触发警告。无论如何，我极力推荐它们。伴随着这个音符，让我们休息一下。当我们回来时，如果我们还没有被取消的话，
You couldn't teach the Flashman books at a university now because of the language. So if you wanted to use them in a course, I mean, they'd have to be preceded by all kinds of trigger warnings about all the material and the way that the Flashman and the narrator describes them. Anyway, I couldn't recommend them highly enough. And on that note, let's take a break. And when we come back, if we haven't been cancelled
我们将看看其中的一些推特。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，
we'll look at some of the tweets I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
并告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的优先预订，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。离别的痛苦不及重逢的喜悦。
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The pain of parting is nothing to the joy of meeting again.
尼古拉斯·尼克尔比。制片人写了所有这些类似幸运饼干风格的东西。所以现在你在贬低狄更斯。你把英语中最伟大的小说家贬低为幸运饼干。哦，多米尼克。现在，狄更斯当然是一位历史小说家，汤姆。所以你通过谈论你认为对固定特定时期形象贡献最大的历史小说，在推特上挑起了事端，不是吗？你认为那是哪一部？是的，好吧，我认为那是《双城记》。事实上，戴维·哈斯基尔确实很好地阐述了这一点。一个问题是：哪些历史小说对公众理解它们所描绘的时期影响最大？它们的影响是变好了还是变坏了？所以，我认为狄更斯的《双城记》可能是对英语世界人们理解一段历史时期影响最大的单一小说，因为尽管狄更斯显然——他汲取了伯克的观点，伯克是第一个真正阐明将法国革命视为恐怖的人——然后卡莱尔，
Nicholas Nickleby. The producer writes all these sort of fortune cookie style. So now you're dissing Dickens. You're dismissing the greatest novelist in the English language as fortune cookie. Oh, Dominic. Now, Dickens, of course, is a historical novelist, Tom. So you've stirred up things on Twitter by talking about the historical novel that you think has done most
也在做同样的事情。狄更斯……你知道的，以他无与伦比的天才，将法国革命的这种形象描绘为——充斥着断头台、女织工（坐在断头台前的人）、囚车、被砍下脑袋的贵族。但也有一种感觉，即贵族是多么的堕落和邪恶，以及他们是罪有应得。法国革命那种严酷的色彩，作为一则道德寓言，确实是由狄更斯为我们定义的。我记得1989年我在巴黎参加革命庆祝活动的二百周年纪念。我记得《世界报》曾问过，七国集团会议正在巴黎举行。哦，我知道你要说到哪里去了。这是玛格丽特·蒂芬妮·撒切尔，对吧？
to fix the image of a particular period, haven't you? And you think that is? Yeah, well, I think that that is A Tale of Two Cities. And in fact, because David Haskier actually puts this, he puts this down very nicely. One question, which works of historical fiction have influenced popular understanding of the period they portray the most and have they done so for the better or the worse so i think that um tale of two cities by dickens is probably the single most influential novel on the way that people in the english-speaking world understand a period of history because although dickens is obviously you know he's drawing on burke who is the first person to kind of really clarify the idea of the french revolution as terror um and then carlisle who is
来固定某个特定时期的形象，不是吗？你认为那是？是的，嗯，我认为那是《双城记》。事实上，因为大卫·哈斯基尔（David Haskier）实际上把这一点表达得非常好。一个问题，哪些历史小说对大众理解其所描绘的历史时期影响最大，它们的影响是好是坏？所以我想，嗯，狄更斯的《双城记》可能是英语世界人们理解某一历史时期最具影响力的单一小说，因为虽然狄更斯显然，你知道，他借鉴了埃德蒙·柏克（Burke），柏克是第一个真正阐明法国大革命是恐怖这一概念的人，然后是托马斯·卡耐尔（Carlyle），他是
is doing the same dickens um you know with his inimitable genius portrays this image of the french revolution as um being awash with, as the guillotine, as tricoteurs, women sitting in front of the guillotine, tumbrils, aristocrats having their heads chopped off. But also the sense of just how depraved and evil the aristocracy are and how they have it coming. And the kind of stark colours of the French Revolution, kind of as a morality tale, is really defined for us by Dickens. And I remember I was in Paris in 1989 for the bicentenary of the celebration of the revolution. Le Monde, I think, asked, the G7 meeting was going on in Paris. Oh, I know where you're going with this. This is Margaret Thatcher, isn't it?
同样，狄更斯，你知道，凭借他那无与伦比的天才，将法国大革命的形象描绘成充满了断头台、织毛衣的妇女（坐在断头台前）、运囚车、贵族被砍头的场景。但同时也传达出贵族是多么的堕落和邪恶，以及他们罪有应得的感觉。法国大革命那种鲜明的色彩，某种程度上作为一个道德故事，确实是由狄更斯为我们定义的。我记得1989年我在巴黎参加革命两百周年庆典。我想《世界报》曾问过，当时G7峰会正在巴黎举行。哦，我知道你要说到哪里去了。这是玛格丽特·撒切尔，对吧？
Yeah, of course. And um le monde asked um all the leaders of the g7 nations for their take on the french revolution and six of them went on about you know uh human rights and liberty and fraternity and equality and all this kind of thing um and mrs thatcher said well it was terrible it was all about agility and thumb drills and things and she obviously got that from um from uh um tale of two cities which i think really does define the french revolution up to this day for the english-speaking world i remember when i was a child in sort of 1970s 1980s britain seeing a a kid's tv program one afternoon, which was about the French Revolution. And I can still remember the scenes of sort of sweaty, horny handed sons of toil bursting into a palace, and all these sort of pretty ladies and waiting hiding in the cupboard, while these sort of
是的，当然。然后呢，呃，“世界报”向呃所有的七国集团领导人征求了他们对法国大革命的看法，其中六个人滔滔不绝地谈论着，你知道，呃，人权、自由、博爱、平等之类的话题，呃，撒切尔夫人则说，嗯，这太糟糕了，全都是关于断头台、拇指夹刑之类的东西。她显然是从呃，呃，呃，查尔斯·狄更斯的《双城记》里得来的印象，我认为这部作品确实为英语世界对法国大革命的认知定下了基调，直到今天依然如此。我还记得当我还是个孩子的时候，大约是在20世纪70年代、80年代的英国，有一天下午看到一个儿童电视节目，内容正是关于法国大革命的。我至今仍能清晰地记那些场景：浑身大汗、粗糙长满老茧的苦工冲进一座宫殿，而那些漂亮迷人的宫廷侍女们则躲在壁橱里，同时这些
slavering dogs of the proletariat dragged them out on their way to the guillotine. So this sort of stuff is very clearly deeply embedded in the kind of Anglo-American, you know, imagination and our sense of the French religion. So I buy that. I suppose, I'm surprised you don't mention I Claudius. Or do you think it's because I Claudius is too obviously based on Suetonius and Tacitus?
无产阶级的凶猛恶犬把她们拖出来，送上断头台。所以这类画面非常清晰且深深地植根于英美人的那种，你知道的，想象力以及我们对法国大革命的印象中。所以我接受这种说法。我想，我只是有点惊讶你没有提到《我，克劳迪斯》（I Claudius）。还是你觉得因为《我，克劳迪斯》太明显是基于苏埃托尼乌斯和塔西佗的著作了？
Yes, yes. I mean, obviously it has its spin, but I think it's going with the grain of the way that Suetonius and Tacitus portray the Roman Empire. And I think that also that was kind of compounded, obviously, by the TV series. I would I would say that the key is novels that have radically altered and transfigured it. So another one would be Walter Scott's Ivanhoe, which is set in medieval England. And I think that that's influential
是的，是的。我的意思是，它显然有自己的艺术加工，但我认为它顺应了苏埃托尼乌斯和塔西佗描绘罗马帝国的那种基调。而且我认为，这种印象显然也被这部电视剧给进一步加深了。我要说的是，关键在于那些彻底改变和重塑了历史的小说。所以另一个例子就是沃尔特·司各特的《艾凡荷》（Ivanhoe），它以中世纪的英国为背景。我认为这部作品非常有影响力，
because that kind of really beds down the idea that medieval England is about Saxons and Normans and that these are completely different people and it's kind of like apartheid South Africa or something, which is still an idea that is very strong in movies and historical fiction to this day. And of course they weave in Robin Hood with Richard the Lionheart,
因为这大大巩固了一种观念，即中世纪的英国就是关于撒克逊人和诺曼人的，而这两群人是截然不同的，就像南非的种族隔离制度一样。这种观念直到今天在电影和历史小说中依然非常强烈。当然，他们还将罗宾汉与狮心王理查的故事交织在一起，
which you're still getting in Prince of Thieves and all that kind of stuff. So I think that's influential. And one last one, which I think has its influence is now basically dissolved is gone with the wind i think that that had a really really seismic influence on how people saw the antebellum south and i think that that now the understand that that has basically dissolved and and no one would regard that as um an authentic vision but i agree with you that gone with the it was very influential for a long time.
你在《盗帅罗宾汉》（Prince of Thieves）以及所有这类作品中依然能看到这些元素。所以我认为这部作品很有影响力。还有一个我认为产生过影响但现在基本上已经消散的作品，那就是《飘》（Gone with the Wind）。我认为这部作品对人们如何看待南北战争前的美国南方产生了真正意义上的、颠覆性的巨大影响。虽然我认为现在人们已经明白这种影响基本上已经消散了，没有人会把那视为一种，呃，真实的愿景，但我同意你的看法，那就是《飘》在很长一段时间里都极具影响力。
I agree with you that Gone With The Wind is colossally important, though I think Gone With The Wind wasn't going against the grain, it was going with the grain of a lot of scholarship in the way that Americans remembered the Civil War and Reconstruction. And of course, Gone With The Wind is also building on the success of Birth of a Nation. So the film in the 1910s that was the film of its day and established that.
我同意你的看法，《飘》具有极其重大的意义，不过我认为《飘》并不是在逆流而动，它其实是顺应了当时美国人记忆中关于内战和重建的大量学术观点。当然，《飘》也是建立在《一个国家的诞生》（Birth of a Nation）的成功之上的。所以20世纪10年代的那部电影，才是那个时代真正的巨作，并确立了这种叙事。
I mean, Birth of a Nation is an incredibly racist film if you watch it now. I used to teach it and it is, I mean, I'm not easily shocked, but it's pretty shocking kind of stuff.
我的意思是，如果你现在去看《一个国家的诞生》，会觉得它是一部极其种族主义的电影。我以前曾教过这部电影，它真的是——我的意思是，我并不是一个轻易会被震惊到的人，但里面的内容实在是相当令人震惊。
And another novel, actually, talking about America and it's kind of mythology of America, might be The Virginian. Yeah. Which is the first kind of Wild West novel. Yes. first kind of wild west novel yes um and and kind of really establishes the template with shootouts and saloon bars and
还有另一部小说，实际上，说到美国及其关于美国的某种神话，可能会是《弗吉尼亚人》（The Virginian）。是的。它可以说是第一部真正意义上的美国西进运动小说。是的。可以说是第一部西部小说，没错，呃，它真正确立了枪战、酒吧和
cattle ranching and everything that then gets picked up by the by the hollywood and i was about to say yeah so i think i think they're good um but actually on on the topic generally of um how accurate uh historical fiction you know, should it be accurate? Does it matter? We've got one from Killian Mabuba, who says film director Stephen Frears once said about historical films, never let facts get in the way of a good story. Do you agree with this approach to historical fiction? Or is there a responsibility for artists to deal in facts when dealing with real historical figures or events? Dominic what do you think? So my take on that would be quite complicated I think if you're writing let's say you write let's stick with novels if you're writing a novel about a
养牛场等所有后来被好莱坞采纳的模板。我正想说呢，是的，所以我认为它们很不错，不过实际上，关于“历史小说究竟应该有多准确？准确性重要吗？”这个普遍话题，我们收到了一位名叫基利安·马布巴（Killian Mabuba）的听众的提问，他说电影导演斯蒂芬·弗雷斯（Stephen Frears）曾这样评价历史电影：“永远不要让事实妨碍了一个好故事。”你认同这种对待历史小说的态度吗？还是说艺术家在处理真实的歷史人物或事件时，有责任遵循事实？多米尼克，你觉得呢？所以，我对这个问题的看法可能会比较复杂。我认为如果你在写——比方说，让我们局限于小说——如果你在写一部关于某个
historical period I think by and large your responsibility is to the novel so you you know if I'm writing a novel about Sasanian Persia or the protectorate of Oliver Cromwell, I don't think my chief responsibility should be to the facts because it's clearly a novel. I think my responsibility is the artistic product of the book and to the readers. Where I think there's possibly a distinction
历史时期的小说，我认为总的来说，你最大的责任是对小说本身负责。所以你知道的，如果我在写一部关于萨珊波斯或奥利弗·克伦威尔护国时期的小说，我不认为我主要的责任应该是对历史事实负责，因为这显然是一部小说。我认为我的责任是对这本书的艺术成果负责，对读者负责。我認為可能存在区别的地方在于，
is where you're dealing with subjects that are very recent. So the relatives of people who were in the book are possible readers. Or it's some sort of incredibly traumatic moment. So, for example, if you were writing a book about the Holocaust, you would obviously's a there's an expectation and a responsibility of sort of fidelity to fact but you know i i'm not one of these people who gets hot under the collar about people have the wrong carriage in the tudors or you know people are carrying the wrong kind of sword in the the sort of bernard cornwell adaptations i mean i think that's completely irrelevant i mean they're clearly fiction so it doesn't matter but when you get to let, let's say, The Crown, the most recent series,
当你处理的题材是非常近期的历史时。书中的人物的亲属可能就是潜在的读者，或者这是某种极其创伤性的时刻。因此，举例来说，如果你在写一本关于大屠杀的书，显然大家会有一种期待，即对历史事实保持忠实，这也是一种责任。但你知道的，我不是那种会因为《都铎王朝》里马车的款式不对，或者伯纳德·康沃尔改编剧里人们拿错了剑而面红耳赤的人。我的意思是，我认为这完全无关紧要。它们显然是虚构作品，所以这根本不重要。但当你接触到，比方说《王冠》（The Crown）最近的几集时，
where the people in it are still alive, I mean, they're human beings with lives. They might be rich and well-known, but they're still human beings like the rest of us. I think the authors should have a responsibility to fairness, I guess is the word. What about you? What do you think? Yeah, I think even with the most sensitive topics, it's possible to engage in fantasy and to make play with the facts. So I think of a recent novel by Colson Whitehead, The Underground Railroad, which weaves the fantastical into the story of slavery
里面的人物依然在世，我的意思是，他们是有血有肉、有自己生活的人。他们可能很富有，也很出名，但他们和我们一样，依然是活生生的人。我认为创作者应该对“公正”负起责任，我想这个词比较合适。你呢？你怎么看？是的，我认为即使在面对最敏感的题材时，也完全有可能发挥想象力，对事实进行艺术加工。所以我想到的是科尔森·怀特黑德（Colson Whitehead）最近的一部小说《地下铁道》（The Underground Railroad），它将奇幻元素交织进了美国南北战争前奴隶制的叙事中，
in the antebellum period in the United States to brilliant effect. And I actually think that a kind of an obsession with realism actually, you know, it's going back to Scott. Basically what you're doing then is you're writing an early 19th century novel. You're writing a novel in the tradition of Walter Scott.
达到了极其辉煌的效果。而且我实际上认为，对现实主义的某种执念，其实——你知道的，这就回到了司各特。基本上你这样做的话，你写的就是一部19世纪初的小说，你是在沃尔特·司各特的传统中写作。
Part of the best way to write a historical novel is actually to accept that an obsession with getting the facts right is actually, you know, quite a recent idea. So that if you're writing about periods where people believe in ghosts or gods or whatever, I think, you know, I don't have any issue at all with them being woven in. I think that can often kind of add to it. So, you know, we mentioned Game of Thrones, but I would say Lord of the Rings actually is, in a sense, a much more creative response to early medieval history than a kind of rigorous attempt to work out exactly what Attila might have said or what the Varangian Guard did.
写历史小说最好的方法之一，其实是接受这样一种观念：对考证事实的执念，本身其实是一个相当近期的想法。因此，如果你在写这样一个时期：当时的人们相信鬼神、各种神灵等等，我想，你知道的，我对于将这些元素编织进故事里没有任何异议。我认为这往往能为作品增色不少。所以，你知道的，我们提到了《权力的游戏》，但我想说的是，《指环王》其实在某种意义上，对早期中世纪历史的创意回应，要远远比那种试图严格弄清阿提拉到底说过什么或瓦兰吉卫队做了什么的严谨尝试要有创造力得多。
I think that, in a sense, letting loose the kind of the moorings that tether you to the known historical facts in certain periods of history can be incredibly liberating. And that's why you would want to read fiction, I think, rather than say straight history. Agreed. And I think there's also a danger, before we move on, that your research can overwhelm you as a novelist. I think that's an issue that some people have actually with Hilary mantel that she wears her research very heavily and there's an enormous amount of stuff about the clothes that they have and the right kind of cloth and the food that they're eating and all that and you can feel the weight of all this stuff that she's done um and perhaps a bit of judicious cutting i mean not that i she's won two prizes so it's not like I know. Yes, I'm sure she'd be grateful for your advice.
我认为，在某种意义上，在特定的历史时期里，解开束缚着已知历史事实的缆绳，可能会带来令人难以置信的解放感。我想这也是为什么你会想去读小说，而不是直接去读正史的原因。完全同意。而且我认为在继续往下谈之前，还有一个危险，那就是作为小说家，你的资料搜集可能会把你压垮。我认为有些人对希拉里·曼特尔（Hilary Mantel）就有这种看法，事实上，她对历史资料的运用显得过于沉重了：书中充斥着大量关于他们穿的衣服、正确布料的材质、他们吃的食物以及所有这些细节，你能感受到她所做的所有研究工作的沉重分量，
Yeah, thanks for watching. I won three. But I agree that with kind of bad historical novelists, that, you know, the dread is the kind of clunking speech. You mean the Duke of York and his three children are coming? Well, they talk in that sort of civil, discontent way. Verily, I'd say to thee, you know, all this kind of stuff. Yes.
也许稍微明智地做些删减会更好——并不是说她没得过奖，她可是赢得了两个奖项的人，所以我也不是在……是的，我确信她会非常感激你的建议。
Anyway. Right, do we have another question? Do we have another question? So Tim Vasby-Burney says, what are our earliest examples... Oh, the reverend Tim Vasby-Burney. Really. He says, what are our earliest examples
好吧，谢谢收看。我得过三个。但我同意，对于那种糟糕的历史小说家来说，（读者）最害怕的就是那种生硬笨拙的台词。你是说：“约克公爵和他的三个孩子要来了吗？”好吧，他们会用那种彬彬有礼却又充满不满的语气说话：“诚哉，我当告于汝……”你知道的，所有诸如此类的话。是的。
of people writing historical fiction? In contrast to, say, writing down myths or embellishing the stories of saints. So you must know the answer to this tom well i if we're talking about historic novels yeah um i mean historical fiction then then it comes slightly you know our medieval romances um you know yes they're not fiction i mean they're not fiction are are they? So I think, well, I think the first novel in kind of the modern West is Cervantes' Don Quixote. And the thing about Don Quixote is that he's driven mad by reading what we would call medieval romance. And the humour in Cervantes is that Don Quixote is a man out of time so we have a portrait of
无论如何。好吧，我们还有另一个问题吗？我们还有另一个问题吗？所以蒂姆·瓦斯比-伯尼（Tim Vasby-Burney）问：我们最早的例子是什么……哦，是牧师蒂姆·瓦斯比-伯尼先生。真的。他说，我们最早的例子是什么
16th century Spain which of course for Cervantes is contemporary Spain yeah you have this man in armor going around um seeing giants instead of windmills and so on so I guess the the Don Quixote is a novel about the tension between the past and the present, you could argue. That's nice. The dynamic of it is generated by the fact that Don Quixote has a sense of reality that is rooted in the historical past rather than in the kind of the dusty reality of Philip II's Spain. And it's a novel with a sense of two things, I guess.
人们开始写历史小说？与那些记录神话或润色圣徒故事的作品相比。所以你一定知道答案，汤姆。嗯，如果我们谈论的是历史小说，对，呃——我的意思是历史小说的话，那么它稍微有点，你知道的，我们的中世纪传奇故事，呃，你知道的，是的，它们不是虚构，我的意思是它们不是虚构，对吧？所以我想，呃，我认为现代西方世界的第一部小说是塞万提斯的《堂吉诃德》。而《堂吉诃德》的精髓在于，他是因为阅读了我们所谓的“中世纪传奇”而陷入疯狂的。塞万提斯的幽默之处就在于，堂吉诃德是一个与时代格格不入的人，所以我们得到了一幅
One, a sense of historical process, so a sense of historical change, that thing that you're talking about. But it's also very postmodern as a book because halfway through the second volume comes out in a world in which Don Quixote has already come out. So Don Quixote is then, you know, people know about him in the story. And they're like, oh, you're the fellow from the book, Don Quixote.
16世纪西班牙的画卷——当然，对塞万提斯来说，这就是他所处的当代西班牙，你会看到这个穿着盔甲的人四处游荡，把风车当成巨人等等，所以我想《堂吉诃德》可以说是一部探讨过去与现在之间张力的小说。这很妙。它所产生的叙事动力源于这样一个事实：堂吉诃德的现实感植根于历史的过去，而不是菲利普二世那尘埃落定的现实西班牙。而且我想这是一部兼具两种意识的小说。
I mean, that's, you know, that's like sort of Martin Amis cropping up in, you know, Martin Amis' own books. I mean, Don Quixote is such an amazing novel because it seems to contain almost the entire future of fiction within it. And was it in the Spanish tradition of historical fiction, it opens up a kind of much more, I think, playful relationship to reality than we have because we're the heirs of Walter Scott. So in the Anglophone tradition, we're absolutely nailed to the sense we've got to get the facts right.
第一，一种历史进程感，也就是一种历史变迁感，也就是你刚才所谈论的那种东西。但它作为一本书也非常后现代，因为在第二卷出版时，故事进行到了一半，它所处的世界里已经出版了第一部《堂吉诃德》。所以在故事中，人们都知道他的存在。他们会说：“哦，你就是书里那个叫堂吉诃德的家伙。”
But in Spain, I think of actually Mexicanican novelist carlos fuentes he wrote he writes this extraordinary novel terra nostra which is a a counterfactual novel in which philip ii has married um elizabeth tudor um and the new world is discovered in his reign and don quixote is a character within that novel. And it's clear that in a sense, he's the kind of destabilising figure, which, and his understanding of reality as being something different to what it is, is what has opened up the kind of fissure
我的意思是，这，你知道的，这就好比马丁·艾米斯突然出现在，你知道的，马丁·艾米斯自己的书里一样。我的意思是，《堂吉诃德》是一部如此惊人的小说，因为它似乎将虚构作品几乎所有的未来都包含在其中了。在西班牙的历史小说传统中，它开启了一种比我们（作为沃尔特·司各特的继承者）所拥有的、与现实更加嬉戏、更加 playful 的关系。所以在英语传统中，我们死死地钉在“必须弄清历史事实”的观念上。
that has enabled this different sense of history to be played with. And you get it in Bourges as well, who's kind of, in his short stories, is brilliant at riffing on history and giving kind of strange angles, elliptical perspectives on it. But actually, the mention of counterfactual... You're going to bring in Jim Longhurst, aren't you?
但在西班牙，我想到了墨西哥小说家卡洛斯·富恩特斯（Carlos Fuentes），他写了一部非凡的小说《特拉诺斯特拉》（Terra Nostra），这是一部反事实小说，在其中，菲利普二世迎娶了伊丽莎白·都铎，新世界在他的统治时期被发现，而堂吉诃德则是这部小说中的一个角色。很明显，在某种程度上，他是一个具有颠覆性的形象，他对现实的理解与现实本身有所不同，正是这种理解撕开了一道裂隙，
Jim Longhurst is waiting off stage. Yes, he is. And his question, what are your thoughts on alternate history novels? In my opinion, the best in the genre recognize how absurd the whole idea is and integrate that critique in the text so you could absolutely say that about um terra nostra carlos frentis's novel um eg the years of rice and salt by kim stanley robinson which is a brilliant novel or the man in the high castle by philip k dick which was a series very recently i think on hbo or something uh so dominic what's your take on counterfactual history so um oh i think it's
使得这种对历史的不同理解得以被演绎和把玩。你在博尔赫斯的作品中也能看到这一点，他在自己的短篇小说中极其擅长对历史进行即兴变奏，给出奇怪的视角和椭圆形的切入点。不过实际上，提到反事实……你一定会把吉姆·隆赫斯特（Jim Longhurst）引进来，对吧？
fine in in novels i mean in a sense all fiction is counterfactual by definition right just like all fiction is historical by definition all fiction is set in a given moment and all fiction um explores something that hasn't happened so i don't have any problem with that and of course we all have a fascination with the what-if question. Even the driest, most desiccated historian can never really resist it. And I think, obviously, the... Well, a good example is,
吉姆·隆赫斯特正在幕后等待着。是的，他确实在。他的问题是：你对架空历史小说有什么看法？依我看，这个流派中最优秀的作品都认识到整个构想是多么荒谬，并将这种批判融入文本之中。所以你完全可以这样评价卡洛斯·富恩特斯的小说《特拉诺斯特拉》；例如金·斯坦利·罗宾逊（Kim Stanley Robinson）那部出色的小说《稻米与盐的年代》（The Years of Rice and Salt），或者是菲利普·K·迪克的《高堡奇人》（The Man in the High Castle），最近这部作品好像刚刚被拍成电视剧，在HBO还是什么平台上播出了。所以，多米尼克，你对反事实历史有什么看法？
everyone would expect me to say Robert Harris. And I guess, you know, Fatherland is a fantastic book. I can well remember being on a bus reading the the last chapter and you know wanting to finish it before I got to my stop but it also won't surprise you Tom to know that I have a very big soft spot for Kingsley Amis's The Alteration which is um uh so have you read that Kingsley Amis's The Alteration? Is that the one about Elizabeth about England not going um about England not going Protestant? England, England,
所以，呃，我认为这在小说里完全没问题。从某种意义上说，所有的虚构作品按定义都是反事实的，对吧？就像所有的虚构作品按定义都是历史性的一样，所有虚构作品都设定在特定的时刻，所有虚构作品都在探索一件并未发生的事情。所以我对此没有任何异议。而且当然，我们所有人对“如果……会怎样”这个问题都有一种天然的迷恋。即便是最枯燥、最干瘪的历史学家，也永远无法真正抗拒它。我想，很显然，一个很好的例子就是，
not going Protestant. The Armada win. Yeah, so it's the story of a boy called Hubert Anvil who's about to become a eunuch. He's about to be castrated so that he can preserve his beautiful
每个人都会期待我提到罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris）。我想，《祖国》（Fatherland）是一本非常棒的书。我依然清晰地记得当年在公共汽车上读最后一章的情景，急切地想在到站前把它读完。不过，汤姆，你知道我非常喜欢金斯利·艾米斯（Kingsley Amis）的《变局》（The Alteration），这也不会让你感到意外吧？所以你读过金斯利·艾米斯的《变局》吗？那是关于伊丽莎白——关于英国没有……关于英国没有变成新教国家的书吗？英国，英国，
singing voice. And America is this sort of, you know, it's this sort of New England Protestant republic that people flee to. So it's a book
没有变成新教国家。无敌舰队获胜了。是的，所以这是一个关于一个叫于贝尔·昂维尔（Hubert Anvil）的男孩的故事，他即将成为一个阉人。他即将被阉割，以便他能保持自己美妙的
very much of its time, I think 1976. So it's a book very much of its own, I think 1976. So it's a book about obviously all Kingsley Amis' strange hang-ups but it's also a book about the Reformation and what would have happened if things had been different. But it's also a book in which Catholic England is standing
歌唱声音。而美国则是那种，你知道的，它是一个人们纷纷逃往的新英格兰新教共和国。所以这是一本
in for the Soviet Union and for the Eastern Bloc and people are fleeing over this cold war with the Protestant world led by America. And it's just an immensely entertaining book in all kinds of ways. And I remember the opening of that and there's a description of Elizabeth's black teeth
非常具有时代烙印的书，我想是1976年出版的。所以这是一本完全属于它自己的时代的书，我想是1976年。所以这本书显然包含了金斯利·艾米斯所有那些奇怪的心理纠结，但它也是一本关于宗教改革的书，探讨了如果事情有所不同将会发生什么。但它也是一本这样的书：一个天主教的英国正在
and she gets shot and her wig has fallen off and her teeth are all black and everything and she dies from the bullet as the Spanish capture Hampton Court or whatever. I would nominate Fatherland. I remember Robert Harris wrote a kind of, a pitch for it in the Sunday Times before it came out.
取代苏联和东欧集团，人们正逃离这场与由美国领导的新教世界之间的冷战。从方方面面来看，它都是一本极其引人入胜的书。我记得书的开篇对伊丽莎白那一口黑牙进行了描述，
And I read it and I was so desperate to read it and it didn't disappoint. And the bit I was remembering that is the Beatles are in it, which really brought home how close. What are they doing? I can't remember that bit. The Beatles are in it which really brought home how close I think what are they doing I can't remember that bit the Beatles are just you know
她被枪击了，假发掉了下来，牙齿全都是黑的，诸如此类，最后随着西班牙人攻占汉普顿宫等情节，她死于枪伤。我还是要提名《祖国》。我记得罗伯特·哈里斯在《星期日泰晤士报》上发表过一篇关于这本书的推介文章，是在它出版前。
they're four lovable mop tops from Liverpool and the Nazis are slightly suspicious about them but let them let them play do they still go to Hamburg
我读了之后就极度渴望阅读，而且它确实没有让人失望。我记得的一个细节是披头士乐队出现在书里，这真的让我深刻体会到到底有多接近。他们在做什么？我不记得那个情节了。披头士乐队出现在里面，这真的让我深刻体会到究竟有多接近——他们在做什么？我不记得那个情节了。披头士乐队只是，你知道的，
presumably they do easier journey I imagine I can't remember I think they're just kind of a mention but I guess it's kind of anchoring you in the fact that actually the 60s
他们是来自利物浦的四个惹人喜爱的蘑菇头青年，纳粹对他们有点疑虑，但还是让他们——让他们去演出。他们还去汉堡吗？
might have been completely different and that really provided a jolt I mean it's kind of anchoring you in the fact that actually the 60s might have been completely different. And that really provided a jolt. I mean, as a kind of serious one, it's mentioned by Jim Longhurst, The Years of Rice and Salt by Kim Stanley Robinson, who is mainly a science fiction writer, very concerned with environmental issues, global warming and habitat loss and all that kind of thing. And Years of Rice and Salt is the Black Death wipes out all the Europeans. And so Europe then gets colonised by Muslims who have not been wiped out. And it then slowly traces the course of what happens. Oh, that's interesting.
大概会的吧，我想旅程会更轻松。我记不清了。我想他们只是被顺带提及了一下，但我想这其实是在强化这样一种事实：60世纪（译者注：原文如此，应为60年代）
Yeah, it's really interesting. And the thing that's interesting about it is unlike most counterfactuals, which are all about kind of Hitler and great men and, you know, people get lost or whatever, this is a kind of much more long durée kind of perspective. And that's why it's rice and salt.
可能完全是另一番景象，这确实给人带来了强烈的震撼。我的意思是，作为一个比较严肃的例子，吉姆·隆赫斯特提到了金·斯坦利·罗宾逊的《稻米与盐的年代》。他主要是一位科幻小说家，非常关注环境问题、全球变暖、栖息地丧失以及所有这类事情。《稻米与盐的年代》讲述的是黑死病消灭了所有欧洲人，因此欧洲随后被没有被消灭的穆斯林殖民。然后它慢慢追溯了接下来发生的事情的发展轨迹。哦，这很有意思。
It's very, very good. Anyway, should we have another question? Yes. Pat Roberts, a good friend of the show, but also kind of picking up on some of the stuff we talked about. Do high status novels set around the time of the author's birth count as historical? Middlemarch, Vanity Fair, Most of Hardy, Some of Dickens,
是的，真的非常有趣。而它有趣的地方在于，与大多数聚焦于希特勒、伟大人物或者人们迷失等主题的反事实小说不同，这部作品拥有一种更为长时段（long durée）的历史视角。这也是为什么它叫《稻米与盐的年代》。它非常、非常棒。不管怎样，我们该问下一个问题了吗？是的。帕特·罗伯茨（Pat Roberts），节目的一位好朋友，同时也接着我们之前讨论过的一些话题提问：以作者出生前后为背景的高水准小说算不算历史小说？比如《米德尔马契》（Middlemarch）、《名利场》（Vanity Fair）、托马斯·哈代的大部分作品、狄更斯的一些作品，
and of course we could include War and Peace. And I think the answer to that is absolutely, isn't it? Yes, yes, it is. I mean, Vanity Fair is a great historical novel. Middlemarch is great. war and peace and i think the answer for that is absolutely isn't it yes yes it is so vanity fair is a is a great historical novel middle march fantasy fantasy fair is a historical novel i think of stondahl's uh the charterhouse of palmer um uh they don't have to be around the time of the author's birth so another question rebecca hutchinson asked about emile zola another french writer and zola is another 19th century writer who's writing about events about 20 or 30 years previous.
当然，我们还可以把《战争与和平》算在内。我认为这个问题的答案绝对是肯定的，对吧？是的，是的，确实如此。我的意思是，《名利场》是一部伟大的历史小说。《米德尔马契》很棒。《战争与和平》也是，所以我认为这个问题的答案绝对是肯定的，对吧？是的，是的，确实如此。所以《名利场》是一部伟大的历史小说，《米德尔马契》——《名利场》是一部历史小说。我想到了司汤达的《帕尔马修道院》（The Charterhouse of Parma）……它们不一定非要以作者出生前后为背景。所以另一个问题是，丽贝卡·哈钦森（Rebecca Hutchinson）问到了另一位法国作家埃米尔·左拉（Émile Zola），左拉也是一位19世纪的作家，他所写的是大约20或30年前发生的事件。
So he was writing about the Franco-Prussian War, for example, and La Débarque. And I think they all are historical novels. And actually, I think often those are the historical novels that were best. So The Tale of Two Cities is an example. It's only 50 years or so between the events before. So the writer can slip
例如，他写的是普法战争，以及《溃退》（La Débâcle）。我认为这些全都是历史小说。事实上，我认为通常这些正是最好的历史小说。《双城记》就是一个例子。这些事件发生的时间距离写作时代只有大约50年左右，所以作家可以
quite easily into the idiom of the day before yesterday yeah and they don't need to sort of affect this sort of bizarre archaic conversational style and nor do they oppress you with the minutiae of detail to show that they've done their research so they just quite easily you know look slightly backwards and the same is true of scott's waverley which i guess is is classically the first historical novel um set in the kind of background of the jacobites and yeah variants and and and that's very much kind of it's it's removed from the time that scott is writing about it but it's kind of within basically living memory. Yeah.
相当轻松地融入前天那个时代的习语中，是的，他们不需要刻意去摆出那种诡异古奥的对话风格，也不会用琐碎的细节来压垮你以证明他们做过详尽的历史调研。他们只是相当自然地，你知道的，略微回望过去。司各特的《威弗利》（Waverley）也是如此，我认为它堪称经典的第一部历史小说，以詹姆斯党起义和……为背景，这在很大程度上是从司各特写作时期的过去截取出来的，但它基本上还在活着的记忆范围内。是的。
People do that now, don't they? I mean, people write books, Jonathan Coe, The Rotter's Club, Philip Hensher, The Northern Clemency. People are writing books set in the 70s and 80s and they're historical novels. Well, Scott was very much conservative. Yes. And you, Dominic, as a leading left-wing historian yeah here's a question
现在人们也这样做，不是吗？我的意思是，人们在写书，比如乔纳森·柯（Jonathan Coe）的《窃贼俱乐部》（The Rotter's Club），菲利普·亨舍尔（Philip Hensher）的《北方仁慈》（The Northern Clemency）。人们在写以70年代和80年代为背景的书，它们就是历史小说。嗯，司各特非常保守。是的。而你，多米尼克，作为一个左翼阵营的杰出历史学家，
for you and it's from william i wrestle with this i wrestle with all this is historical fiction typically conservative scott dickens talking i don't think dickens is conservative i mean dickens is ambiguous isn't he dickens is very ambiguous he's very much he's you know we talked about this before he's very much in favor of um philanthropists turning up and scattering gold but his his his moral sense of moral anger at poverty and so i don't think he's he's really conservative but anyway scott and tolkien uh they're definitely conservative change being estranging and chaotic and continuity a guarantor of freedom and hope yeah and that's also that uh the ethos of the leopard the book i mentioned earlier the lamp Tomasi de Lampedusa book. Tolstoy, again, an ambiguous figure, I guess, both conservative. I guess the question is, is the process of looking back to the past
这里有个问题要抛给你，来自威廉：“我对此感到纠结，我对这一切都感到纠结：历史小说通常都是保守的吗？司各特、狄更斯……”说到狄更斯，我不认为狄更斯是保守的。我的意思是，狄更斯模棱两可，不是吗？狄更斯非常模棱两可。他非常——你知道的，我们之前讨论过这一点——他非常赞成慈善家出现并散播金钱，但他对贫困的道德义愤是如此强烈，所以我认为他真的算不上保守派。不过无论如何，司各特和托尔金——他们绝对是保守的。变化被视为异化和混乱，而连续性则是自由和希望的担保人。是的，这也是……这也是兰佩杜萨（Tomasi de Lampedusa）的书——我刚才提到的那本书《豹》（The Leopard）中的精神内核。托尔斯泰，同样是一个模棱两可的人物，我想，两者都带有保守色彩。我想问题在于，回顾过去这一过程，
rather than writing about the present, is that not in itself inherently a conservative thing to do? Yes, it probably is in some ways, isn't it? I don't think people tend to look back in the past. Very rarely do people look back to the past and write books that are shot through with horror about the period they're writing about. They tend to write out of love, don't they, do you think?
而不是书写当下，这难道本身不是一种本质上保守的做法吗？是的，从某些方面来说可能确实如此，不是吗？我不认为人们往往会回头看过去。人们极少会回顾过去，写出充斥着对他们所写那个时代感到恐惧的书籍。他们往往出于爱意而写作，不是吗，你觉得呢？
Well, an interesting one, and you might say that this was the very first historical novel, would be Defoe's Record of the Plague Year. Okay. I mean, he's writing that when, kind of 70 years after the Great Plague of London. But he writes it so convincingly that everyone now treats it as a,
嗯，一个有趣的例子——你可能会说这其实是第一部历史小说——那就是笛福的《大疫年记》（A Journal of the Plague Year）。好吧。我的意思是，他在伦敦大瘟疫大约70年后写下了这本书。但他写得如此令人信服，以至于现在每个人都把它当作
you know, an actual record of what went on. But it's not, but it's not, is it a conservative book? I mean, I don't think you, I wouldn't, I don't know enough about it. No, but he's writing, it's a novel that is about horror, I guess. Yeah.
一份真实记录当时发生的事情的档案。但它并不是，它不是，对吧？这是一本保守的书吗？我的意思是，我不认为你——我不会，我对它了解得不够多。不，但他在写作，这是一本关于恐惧的书，我想。是的。
Teller to Cities, which you mentioned, is clearly a conservative book, isn't it? Yeah, very, I think. Yeah. Thus exploding your claim that Dickens was not a conservative writer. Well, as we said, it's ambivalent because his portrayal of the brutality of the regime is absolutely brilliant.
你刚才提到的《双城记》，显然是一本保守的书，不是吗？是的，我认为非常是。是的。从而粉碎了你关于“狄更斯不是保守派作家”的断言。嗯，正如我们所说，它是矛盾的，因为他对政权残暴的描绘绝对是绝妙的。
I mean, the count of the Monseigneur with his chocolate who rides out in his carriage and they knock over the small boy. That's right. And the bereaved father who pursues him and kills him in the chateau is, you know, I mean, you wouldn's necessarily no you're right a conservative writing i mean there's kind of yeah there's kind of tension there anyway i'd say i think that's a kind of a reserved yes to that answer isn't it i think um what else should we do um we've done rebecca hutchinson oh here's a good one uh love reynolds and graves for the first person approach and war and Peace for tackling the whole question of who's writing history or is history writing itself. That's from Tobin Ober.
我的意思是，那个喝着巧克力、骑着马车外出却撞倒了小男孩的蒙赛涅尔伯爵（Monseigneur）。没错。还有那个追赶他并在城堡里杀死他的悲痛欲绝的父亲，你知道的——你不会一定觉得……不，你是对的，一个保守派在写作。我的意思是，那里有一种，呃，某种张力存在。无论如何，我想我对这个问题的答案会给出一个有所保留的“是的”，不是吗？我想，呃，我们还应该讨论什么，呃，我们讨论过丽贝卡·哈钦森了。哦，这里有一个很好的问题：“我喜欢雷诺兹（Renault）和格雷夫斯（Graves）的第一人称叙事视角，也喜欢《战争与和平》对‘究竟是谁在书写历史，还是历史在书写它自己’这一宏大问题的探讨。”这是托宾·奥伯（Tobin Ober）提的。
Okay, so the question of first-person narratives over kind of third-person omniscient narrator. Do you have opinion on which works better? So Tobin Ober mentions Mary Renner, who we haven't mentioned at all it's mary reynolds dominic yeah mary reynolds shocking it's it really is mary reynolds of all the people of all the people to affect a french pronunciation i would be the last that anyone would um expect anyway so that book's the persian boy and the middle one in the Alexander trilogy, and the best one, I think.
好的，那么关于第一人称叙事与第三人称全知视角孰优孰劣的问题。你对哪种效果更好有什么看法吗？所以托宾·奥伯提到了玛丽·雷诺（Mary Renault），我们之前完全没有提到过她——她是玛丽·雷诺，多米尼克。是的，玛丽·雷诺，太惊人了！这真的是——玛丽·雷诺！在所有人当中，居然由一个最不可能……去刻意模仿法国发音的人来谈论她，我大概会是最后一个……无论如何，那本书是《波斯男孩》（The Persian Boy），是亚历山大三部曲中的第二本，也是我认为最好的一本。
And it's narrated by the eunuch Bagoas, who Alexander picks up. The most hideous description of a castration, which still makes me want to cross my legs just thinking about it. And I think it works actually pretty well. I mean, it sounds like a ridiculous idea for a novel. I'm going to basically have a Persian eunuch narrate the conquests of Alexander the Great in this, again, in a novel which is an inherently kind of 18th, 19th century literary form.
它的叙述者是亚历山大收留的波斯阉人巴戈阿斯（Bagoas）。书中对阉割过程进行了最可怕的描述，光是想想就依然让我想要双腿并拢。而且我认为它的效果其实相当不错。我的意思是，让一个波斯阉人来叙述亚历山大大帝的征服过程，这听起来像是一个荒谬绝伦的小说构想，而且这本书本身，同样也是一部本质上属于18-19世纪文学形式的小说。
But I think it can work if there's an integrity to the narrative voice, I guess. Absolutely. And I think with Mary Rennell in particular, I think the integrity comes from the kind of the strangeness of the fact that she is a woman in a relationship with another woman, ventriloquising a man, or in the case of Bagavassa, a boy. A boy. Who in turn are then sleeping with men. So there's a kind of ripple effect of disorientation happening there. And actually, Reynolds' books are kind of authentically true to the spirit of ancient Greece in their kind of, by our standards, incredible chauvinism. And I remember in Far From Heaven, which is the first in that series about
但我认为，只要叙事声音具有内在的一致性，它就能发挥作用。绝对是的。而且我认为特别是对玛丽·雷诺来说，这种一致性的来源在于一种奇特性：她作为一个女人，与另一个女人保持着恋爱关系，却在小说里用男性的口吻（或者像巴戈阿斯那样，是一个男孩的口吻）来进行腹语般的创作。一个男孩。而这个男孩转过头来又和男人们睡觉。所以这里发生了一种迷失方向的涟漪效应。事实上，雷诺的书在某种程度上真实地还原了古希腊的精神内核——按照我们的标准来看，那种不可思议的沙文主义。我还记得在《天堂远去》（Fire from Heaven）——那是她关于亚历山大童年和青年时期系列小说的第一本——里面有一个令人惊叹的描写，雷诺借亚历山大之口说：“我可不愿意当个女人。她们就像鸟儿一样叽叽喳喳，只能住在笼子里，不能像男人那样——像我们这样。我们可以走出去做各种事情。”然后你会想，好吧，你知道的，这其实是一个女人写的。它拉开了一段距离，
Alexander's childhood and youth, there's a kind of amazing description where Reynolds, ventriloquizing Alexander, says, I'd hate to be a woman. They kind of, you know, they twitter like birds and they just have to live in cages and they cannot be like men, like we are. We go out and do things. And then you think, well, you know, it's a woman writing this. And it kind of sets up it it it distances you i think from the present and it that i think is part of the power of those novels that it unsettles our understanding of fairly fundamental notions like sex like gender in a way that may not be necessarily true to how greeks in the fourth century actually thought. But by destabilising our understanding of them,
它拉开了你与当下的距离，我认为这正是这些小说力量的一部分，它打破了我们对诸如性别、性等相当基础的概念的理解，这种方式或许并不完全符合公元前4世纪希腊人实际的想法。但通过解构我们对它们的理解，
it kind of does take you into a different sphere, which I think is what historical fiction should do. And I wonder, you know, going back to Flashman, I wonder whether one of the issues at the moment in writing historical fiction is that there are too many taboos, that the moral sense of what is acceptable is changing so fast that
它确实把读者带入了一个不同的领域，而我认为这正是历史小说应该做到的事情。我在想，（顺便说一句）回到《弗莱斯曼》（Flashman），我在想目前写历史小说面临的问题之一，是不是禁忌太多了？人们对什么是“可接受的”道德观念变化得如此之快，
actually it it almost becomes dangerous to go back and and um essentially articulate mainstream views in earlier periods because they would just seem unacceptable to to so many readers now i mean i don't know i think i'm sure that's true because one one of my favourite books set in the past, I suppose, would be, well, a couple of them, Cormac McCarthy's Blood Meridian. Oh, yes. You know, that's such a powerful book. But again, a book that if it was published today, would probably get a different reaction from when it was published in, I think, the mid-80s. Right. And so we should just assume to people who haven't read that. Yeah, it's looking back to... So it's set on the borderlands between Mexico and the United States
以至于回到过去，去本质上阐述早期时期的主流观点，几乎变成了一件危险的事，因为这在现在的许多读者看来会显得完全不可接受。我的意思是，我不知道，我确信是这样的，因为我过去读过的以过去为背景的最喜欢的书之一，我想会是——其中有几本——麦卡锡（Cormac McCarthy）的《血色子午线》（Blood Meridian）。哦，是的。你知道的，那是一本极具震撼力的书。但同样，如果这本书是在今天出版的，它引发的反应可能会和它在80年代中期出版时大不相同。所以我们应该向那些没读过这本书的人简要说明一下。是的，它是回溯到……所以它的背景设定在墨西哥和美国之间的边境地带，
in about 1850. And it follows a boy who is part of a gang of scalp hunters. So they're literally just going around killing people, effectively raping and pillaging. But it's told in this incredibly bleak, dark, bloody way. Kind of like Milton and King James Bible, isn't it? Just utterly overwhelming. Very heightened.
大约在1850年左右。它讲述了一个男孩的故事，他加入了一帮头皮猎人。所以他们实际上就是在四处杀人，实际上就是在强奸和劫掠。但它是用这种极其阴暗、黑暗、血腥的风格讲述的。有点像弥尔顿和《詹姆士国王圣经》，不是吗？简直令人透不过气来。情感高度紧绷。
And it's got this, as you say, it's got this kind of epic moralism kind of hanging over it. So the sense that what's happening appears to be quite small scale, but actually it's got this apocalyptic... It feels like the end of the world, doesn't it? It's like...
正如你所说，它上面悬着这种史诗般的道德主义。所以那种正在发生的事情看起来规模很小，但实际上它带有这种末日般的……感觉就像是世界末日，不是吗？就像……
Yeah, and I think... Same style that he uses in The Road. Yeah, and I think that that's an example of how realism is banished because there's this terrifying figure, The Judge, who's this kind of hairless albedo who... He's the most frightening character in fiction, isn't he? Yes, and I think he's basically...
是的，而且我认为……他在《长路》（The Road）里用的也是这种风格。是的，我认为这是一个如何摒弃现实主义的例子，因为书中有一个可怕的人物——法官（The Judge），他是一个没有毛发、白化病般的家伙……他是小说中最吓人的角色，不是吗？是的，而且我认为他基本上是——
At the end, it's kind of implied that he's the devil, and I don't think that I'm giving away any spoilers. He's immortal, that he's a kind of immortal representative of the impulse to destroy and kill and rape and murder. Yeah, so, no, I think that would still, I mean, I don't think anyone would think to censor Cormac McCarthy. I suppose. Because I think his greatness is too evident.
在书的结尾，隐约暗示他就是魔鬼，我想我并没有剧透。他是永生的，他是毁灭、杀戮、强奸和谋杀冲动的某种永恒代表。是的，所以，不，我想这仍然——我的意思是，没有人会想到去审查麦卡锡。我想是的。因为我认为他的伟大是显而易见的。
Maybe, maybe. Or what about, say, Absalom Absalom by William Faulkner? So that's a very difficult book. It's looking back to the, I mean, it's sort of difficult to read because Faulkner has a very dense sort of style. But also it's looking back to the Civil War, the American Civil War and the stain of slavery in the American South. So there's a lot of kind of very charged stuff about race in there that I think readers, a lot of modern readers, would find
也许吧，也许吧。或者比方说，威廉·福克纳（William Faulkner）的《押沙龙，押沙龙！》（Absalom, Absalom!）呢？所以那是一本非常难读的书。它的背景回溯到——我的意思是，它很难读，因为福克纳有一种非常密集凝练的风格。但同时它也回溯到了内战、美国内战以及美国南方蓄奴制的污点。所以里面有很多关于种族的极具冲击力的内容，我想许多现代读者会觉得
very unsettling. I mean, the language is obviously, you know, language that people wouldn't use now, for example. Yeah. So, Tom, let's wrap up with, I mean, there's so many tweets and I'm sorry we haven't been able to get through more than a fraction of them, but we'll end with John Sargent's tweet. He says, if only one book on history, which was fiction, survived the coming apocalypse, the zombies, the lizard Illuminati overlords launching Armageddon, what book would that be to restart history as something humans do? So one historical novel that would survive. Tom, what would you choose?
非常不安。我的意思是，语言显然是——你知道的，人们现在不会再使用的语言，比如说。是的。所以，汤姆，让我们来做个总结吧——我的意思是，有那么多的推文，很抱歉我们只能处理其中的一小部分——但我们将以约翰·萨金特（John Sargent）的推文来结尾。他说：“如果历史上的虚构书籍中，只有唯一的一本在即将到来的末日、僵尸、蜥蜴人光明会统治者发动世界末日核战后幸存下来，作为人类行为的历史重新开始，那会是哪本书呢？”所以，会是哪一本幸存下来的历史小说呢？汤姆，你会选哪一本？
I think I would choose probably Walter Scott's Waverley on the assumption that that really is the kind of the fountainhead of historical fiction, I think. I don't think it most gripping i don't i don't think it's the most enjoyable i think it's perhaps the most influential um i think without that novel historical fiction as we have it now wouldn't be quite the same um well i'm tempted to say flashman because it's the funniest but i mean the idea of the future human civilization being based on Flashman is probably one of my disturbing thoughts. Yeah, very disturbing thought. So maybe I should pick, maybe for sentimental reasons,
我想我可能会选择沃尔特·司各特的《威弗利》，基于这样一个假设：这确实是历史小说的发源地，我认为是的。我不认为它是最引人入胜的——我、我不认为它最具有可读性，但我认为它也许是最具影响力的。呃，我想如果没有那本小说，我们现在所拥有的历史小说就不会是现在这个样子了。呃，虽然我很想说是《弗莱斯曼历险记》（Flashman），因为它是最搞笑的，但我的意思是，让未来的整个人类文明建立在《弗莱斯曼历险记》的基础之上，这大概是我所能想到的最令人不安的想法之一了。是的，非常令人不安的想法。所以也许我应该挑选——也许出于感伤的原因，
I'll pick the first historical novel that I remember reading, which is, what's the historical novel I suppose it is? It's Antonia Fraser's book about King Arthur and the Knights of the Round Table. Have you ever read that? No. She wrote that when she was in her 20s. I mentioned it once in an article in the Daily Mail. I got an email from Antonia Fraser, which I was very excited by.
我会挑选我记得自己读过第一本历史小说，那就是——我想象中的那本历史小说是什么？是安东尼娅·弗雷泽（Antonia Fraser）关于亚瑟王和圆桌骑士的书。你读过那本吗？没有。那是她在20多岁时写的。我在《每日邮报》的一篇文章中提到过一次。我收到了安东尼娅·弗雷泽发来的一封电子邮件，这让我感到非常兴奋。
And she said, I can't believe you remember this book. I wrote it when I was in my 20s. I would come home at night and I had this commission to write this book and I would bang out 500 words on Solancelot or something before I went out partying. And I've still got my copy, my copy, which is also the first book I ever wrote my name in. So there's this illegible scrawl in Antonio Fraser's King Arthur, which is the first ever recorded instance of the words Dominic Sandbrook. So one day, Tom, that book will be worth a colossal amount of money. OK, but so people are recovering from the mutation zombies
她说：“我真不敢相信你还记得这本书。我写它的时候才20多岁。我晚上回家，接到了写这本书的委约，然后在出门派对狂欢之前，我会疯狂码出500字关于兰斯洛特或其他什么的内容。”而且我还保留着我的那本，我的那本书，这也是我第一次在上面写下自己名字的书。所以在安东尼娅·弗雷泽的《亚瑟王》上有这样一行字迹潦草的涂鸦，这也是“多米尼克·桑德布鲁克”（Dominic Sandbrook）这个名字最早的有据可查的出处。所以有一天，汤姆，那本书将会价值连城。好吧，所以人们正在从基因突变的僵尸中恢复过来，
and they think, well, to do history, you've got to have people handing out swords from lakes and... Yes, love it. Yeah, right. Why not? What are you going to choose? Hard Times? I've just chosen Waverley. That's hardcore, realist history.
他们会想，好吧，要想搞历史，你必须得有人从湖里递出宝剑之类的……是的，太棒了。是的，没错。为什么不呢？你要选哪本？《艰难时世》（Hard Times）？我刚选了《威弗利》。那是硬核的现实主义历史。
Anyway, that's all we've got time for, I think. Let's move on. Dominic, are you going to do the graces and finish us off? So, it's a far, far better thing than I do, than I've ever done. It's a far, far better rest, or in my case, dinner, that I go to than I've ever known. Goodbye from me. And it's bye from me.
总之，我想我们的时间就到这里。我们继续吧。多米尼克，你要做祷告并为我们做个结语吗？嗯，这是一件比我以往所做的好得多、好得多的事。我要去一个比我以往所知的更好、更好的休憩之所，或者对我的情况来说，是更好的晚餐。再见，来自我。再见，来自我。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。